You are solving a system
of two linear equations
in two variables.
You have found more
than one solution
that satisfies the system.
Which of the following
statements is true?
So before even reading
these statements,
let's just think
about what's going on.
So let me draw my axes here.
Let's draw my axes.
So this is going to
be my vertical axis.
That could be one
of the variables.
And then this is
my horizontal axis.
That's one of the
other variables.
And maybe, for sake of
convention, this could be x,
and this could be y, but they're
whatever our two variables are.
So it's a system of
two linear equations.
So if we're graphing them,
each of the linear equations
in two variables can be
represented by a line.
Now, there's only
three scenarios here.
One scenario is where the
lines don't intersect at all.
So the only way
that you're going
to have two lines in two
dimensions that don't intersect
is if they have the
same slope and they
have different y-intercepts.
So that's one
scenario, but that's
not the scenario that's
being described here.
They say, you have found
more than one solution
that satisfies the system.
Here there are no solutions.
So that's not the scenario
that we're talking about.
There's another
scenario where they
intersect in exactly one place.
So they intersect in
exactly one place.
There's one point, one
xy-coordinate right over there
that satisfies both
of these constraints,
but this also is not the
scenario they're talking about.
They're telling us that you have
found more than one solution
that satisfies the system.
So this isn't the
scenario either.
So the only other scenario
that we can have-- we
don't have parallel lines
that don't intersect.
We don't have lines that
only intersect in one place.
The only other scenario is that
we're dealing with a situation
where both linear
equations are essentially
the same constraint.
They both are
essentially representing
the same xy-relationship.
That's the only way that
I can have two lines,
and this only applies to
linear relationship and lines.
But the only way that
two lines can intersect
more than one place is if
they intersect everywhere.
So in this situation,
we know that we
must have an infinite
number of solutions.
So which of these
choices say that?
This one right here-- "there are
infinitely many more solutions
to the system"--
right over there.